i'm going to start with congratulations
on the movie you guys did such a great
job i love this film and i'm out i'll
see you guys later
all right thank you
um but one of the things that i love
about tik tik boom is that it reminds
you how precious life is and how you
should take every moment um and make the
best of it can you sort of talk about
did being part of this production and
telling this story maybe impact your
real life in terms of the way you want
to live
i would say for me absolutely you know
i'm a father of three i have seven month
old twins
and i got to shoot this at a time uh
before just a couple months before they
were born last fall
and so the theme of
every moment being precious and being
aware of how you spend your time that we
saw jonathan larson live through and and
wrestle with is something that hits me
so deeply makes me want to trim the fat
off every thing that's not necessary
everything that i'm sweating
that doesn't make any sense um to get my
ego out of the way and just do the
things that are important
um yeah so it definitely hit me like
that you want to add anything
um i mean yeah i think that that's a
through line in jonathan larson's work
um and something that turned a fan
out of me almost instantly you know i
remember the first time i did rent and
and singing no day but today and how
that really embedded itself onto my
heart and soul and and made me
really look at my life and and reassess
you know am i doing what i should be
doing with the time that i have and i
feel like it's really important to ask
yourself that continuously throughout
the years it doesn't matter the time
because it's really important to
constantly prioritize and priorities
shift you know so you have to stay on
track and stay on top of yourself a bit
um if you guys could actually show
jonathan a scene from this movie what
scene would you pick and why
oh my gosh
you know what
one of my favorite moments in the film
is the last one
um where they're singing louder than
words
and carissa and roger are characters
after our last vocal line
we look at at andrew's character
jonathan
because we know he has the next line
and
we know that the uh how much it took for
him to write this song and what it means
to him
and you know i'm so glad alice and lynn
that you captured this because we look
at him as our fearless leader
genius who holds the future of the art
form in his hands
and that look means so much i'm so glad
that they they left that in there it's
it's friends supporting their friend
um through a hard time knowing that he's
got a special gift to give to the world
i'm i'm stuck between two um
oh man three that's so hard
either either come to your senses
um
therapy and those two because of
of the way that lynn took those numbers
and and digested them
and then
turned them into a very unique
experience for the audience um i feel
like he he would be thrilled with seeing
how that turned out and also play game
because
jonathan wanted to write musicals for
the mtv generation and play game looks
like a 90s um music video and i feel
like he would have just been over over
the moon to see that like really come
into fruition
uh
i loved andrew's performance in this i
felt like jonathan had come back to life
for the two hours that i was watching
and i am very curious what it was like
for the two of you seeing
what he was doing on set and just that
energy that he was exhibiting i mean
it's it's unbelievable
he was willing to dive into the unknown
you know when you see an artist bring
all their research and their entire
instrument to something but still leave
so much room to
to to uh be a vessel for jonathan's
spirit you know we saw him just like i
felt like he was just throwing colors on
the wall early and then all of a sudden
there became a pattern and then there
was a character and like you say more
mannerisms came in and and every day he
became john more and more and he turned
around in the middle of film and you're
like who are we talking to right now
like this this is jonathan yeah it
literally got to the point where i think
we were in a conversation and andrew
walked by and i was like oh john
i just called him john i did not mean to
do that at all but he just fully
embodied him in in every moment and it
was just so so beautiful to to have him
there and to be a fan and to be a
supporter as a human being but also a
character you know it just felt like we
we didn't even have to like act we were
just literally there to support and do
what we love
on that note i got to stop again i just
want to say congrats and thank you for
giving me your time and i really hope
it's a huge hit thank you so much good
to see you take care thanks to see you
later
you